following from the
the last film talking about key
most people are just happy to do aikido
that's not most things in life you know
that
either we have interests or we're not
interested
why did we choose the particular teacher
you'll all have different uh reasons why
but um the masters i was talking about
earlier
if osensis said that cochito was his
greatest ever student in his opinion
why would somebody pick
you know chiba scentsy is it because he
was in this country
possibly
i had the advantage of traveling around
the world
following cytoscency and because
he knew so many and because of his
high rank and being
a sense his side for
an unbroken 23 24 years
i didn't know exactly the amount
and he wasn't really very well known
because
he just worked on the railway until he
was 50 and then retired
and then the world started to get to
know him more before that he didn't
really go out much
and all the other masters they'd they'd
been in the world a long
time before that so
people who like myself who could travel
you could you could search out the
master that impressed you all you liked
we didn't have many films though we
didn't
we didn't have internet we couldn't
really
you had to ask anyone
when i was traveling to see such a
scentsy
i'd travel to every continent in the
world
eventually to to see him and i used to
do this
i said before twice a year if i could
it was like a top up i just needed the
top up
i remember him meeting uh tomorrow
scentsy
now tomorrow sensei and him were like
two
young school children when they met
um and the sad thing is the japanese
culture
is they they like drinking
and they get drunk together and oh
they've been like
laughing and giggling like reminiscing
about the past
and i was listening to them one
one time they were speaking japanese of
course
yet tomorrow was based in france
he was the the head the head now i think
i don't know how him and noah have gone
no another subject
anyway they were laughing and that
and i asked somebody who could
understand translate what what was
making them so happy and he still they
were talking about
when they were on the mat with osensi
and how narrow sense he didn't like
spiders
and they were training in iwama together
and because they were
best mates such as sentient tomorrow
scentsy
they thought they'd have a joke and uh
they found one of these big spiders
you know the sort the ones that come out
of the fields they're really
quite huge now their legs span about
i don't know five to seven centimeters
we get a lot in the countryside
anyhow one would
decide to um grab a spider
and when uh when they could get
near no essentially while while training
this was in front of her scentsy
one would pop the spider in the top of
not
normal sets his key because they were
just students there they weren't big
masters they were just
like a lot of us just students trying to
get better
and of course noah would also feel the
spider inside him
so open his panic
must be a horrible feeling if you'll
find the spiders
he would go running off the mat you know
doing this and shaking himself
and they were talking about how
did each one remember those senses
saying
that boy's crazy and
um i sense he never did know what was
making nora crazy
but this was something that they would
do
periodically once they found a weakness
and so it was a joyful training as well
as a hard training but even in front of
her scentsy
they'd still have time to have fun
i was fortunate enough when
psychosensitive was invited to teach in
paris
to train with tamura sensei
his aikido was completely different
psychosensi
and i thought well why is it so
different
you know they were trained by the same
person no sensing
they were best mates
why isn't it like you do exactly the
same
but do you know anybody who's like you
know is exactly the same because i don't
there's a lot of look there's a lot of
people who look
like they're teachers yes i can look at
students and
tell who their teachers are on a seminar
there might be a hundred
people on the seminar and i go around
and i just
i won't say names now but i can
point out who their teachers are it's
not a game it's just that they've
copied the teachers so well
that they they look like them in stature
and
postures and the way they execute the
throws
where they execute the techniques
but that's not themselves
and one day i hope they will all find
themselves
most people do and as
as i've seen a lot of people
they change and they change the
aikido and i was talking about al
kanetska
changed when someone like me grabbed him
who was taught a completely different
score
with a maximum force and not just a
following
mind of flowing that he was my sensei
i grabbed him and attacked him
one hundred percent and
it gave him what he asked and he had to
deal with it
now i was talking about key in daily
life to me key in daily life
is using your common sense using your
intuition
but there's a lot of things we don't see
a massive things we don't see
and those things um
perhaps never will
be of interest to us now there was a
book but
i'd like to just show you here
and it's about water and this professor
studied this
you'll see it says new york times
bestseller
how can it be a bestseller about
the hidden messages in water
it goes on to say like snowflakes
all the crystals being different not one
crystal
being alike can anybody prove it i don't
know perhaps they can't
we can't look at every snowflake that's
ever fallen can we
but in that book he goes on
to talk about
how you feel holding a glass of water
now it changes the crystals
these three items that i've got here
if i boil the kettle
what one would you say put the hot water
in
i think we all agree definitely not the
flute class
mainly designed for champagne
this is quite a robust glass but the
good thing about this constant
it's a basic strong place
it's got a nice thick rim
a good sturdy base
so that's a base that's what we call a
basic
this is to me enough
the flute glass very delicate
very thinly this is what i would call
the humble style
like today not really ikikai because i
could cry
as i've already said the teacher makes
a star depending on how they see the
demand of ricotta
so that brings us to the the kettle and
the water
you'll see now because it's a glass
cattle
you'll see how it's starting to
get warm
and about now is the time i should be
making the pour of that water
if i just leave it because it's friendly
i think i look at the water friendly
now it's starting to get
angry can you say the way it's getting
angrier and angrier you could say more
powerful more dynamic
it's changing now whatever you think
let's
say go with my theory that if i poured
that water
while it was in the angry states
if the water crystals change with how i
feel would i change
with how the water feels
am i that sensitive no of course i'm not
but if i use key in daily life
and i said earlier that the key you know
comes out like the hose pipe of shooting
energy
it comes from internal stream
what if i was absorbing the waters
feelings
that is nature as much
of part of nature as i do as my own body
if i poured that while it was angry
then would i be affected internally
like an individual crystal
it's just something to consider for you
to consider
you may consider whether i'm mad or not
but i try not to pour a cup of tea
because i like my tea while the water's
boiling i always try and get to the
kettle first
or i allow the kettle right now
to become still again hoping that
it's calm and the water is feeling
comfortable
i could think the other way i mean it's
my mind i could think
oh i'll pour it when it's bubbling and
really
powerful because then i will feel
powerful
i'm sort of deciding for the water
itself aren't i
where the person that's reading this
book
he's telling me how if you hold a glass
of water in your hands and have good
thoughts
the crystals change if you have bad
aggressive thoughts they change again
so there's a lot going on that we'll
never know about perhaps not even care
about
but to me keen daily life
is using something far deeper
than we ever really look for on the mat
the yellow mug is obviously
the best thing to put tea in if i want
to put tea in
but what about if i was going
on a trek i was going camping for six
months
i'd get my rucksack and fill it with all
the
the things
and i would either go to the shop and
get some advice
from the people that know wonder if this
your student asks you since i've never
been camping before
can you advise me
take a mug but better still
take a metal mug because a metal mug
you can put anything from
champagne in it
to warm liquids
be careful too hot it could crack
this one you can put anything hot or
cold in it
but it it could get the handle broken
but you could still hold it but being
porcelain
if you're going hiking if you
happen to sit back on your rucksack it
could break if it's against the rock
so go and buy yourself a metal one but
one with a handle just like this
this is my suggestion to you
you would hopefully tell the student
because it will do
everything it's basic
but this is key in daily life key
is good internal spirit
we could say good internal intuition
good common sense
going on from that my second book
keeping the mind of a child
i wrote this for those people who are
looking for more spiritual
understanding to understand or to at
least
consider the water crystals consider
do you want to switch the kettle off
before it pours
or do you want to let it settle so that
is calm
perhaps you're just really looking at a
mirror a mirror of yourself
how you'd like to be how you would like
to think
keeping the mind of a child
if you asked a child those questions
about the glasses and the mugs
they wouldn't know it takes an adult
who's left a little while to know this
but the honesty behind it the internal
feeling
of the cleanness and the honesty usually
comes from
a child so going back to that inside
yourself
to me is very important i hope you've
enjoyed this
it's very different to me it is aikido
please leave your comments and subscribe
to my channel
if you're interested in time i will go
on to more technical
but at the moment everybody seems to be
showing you aikido
techniques demonstrations
i'd like i wish to talk more as i do
about the philosophy of how i see aikido
as a whole and perhaps even though my
master coach italy wasn't my master
he taught me a lot through thinking
about
why he ventured from a very physical
aikido style to a very
soft key style
that developed the internal
as well as the external thank you